c'est la désolation désespoir
frustration et colère voici le genre
d'émotions éprouvés par la population en
afrique du sud je suis actuellement à
l'aéroport oliver tambo de johannesburg
le principal aéroport international du
pays comme vous pouvez le constater
l'aéroport est pratiquement désert une
situation très différente de celle que
nous avons constatée il ya très peu de
temps alors que des milliers de
personnes arrivées ici tentant
désespérément de prendre place à bord de
n'importe quel vol disponible suite à
l'annoncé concernant la plupart des
voyages internationaux à destination et
en provenance de six états africains
cette annonce a été vécue comme une
surprise des gens qui étaient déjà assis
à bord des avions prêts à décoller ont
dû débarquer des avions qui étaient en
plein vol ont dû faire demi tour et
revenir
la situation est telle que des dizaines
de milliers de personnes sont désormais
coincés ici en afrique du sud des
personnes qui ont besoin de se
rapprocher urgemment de leur lieu de
travail ou de leurs familles dans le
même temps tant de personnes dont
beaucoup de sud-africains sont à
l'étranger cherchant désespérément à
regagner le pays bon nombre d'entre eux
n'ont pas eu la possibilité de retrouver
leur pays ces deux dernières années ils
ont des proches sur place dont certains
sont malades ou âgées et qui n'attendent
que de les revoir
je suis dévasté je me sens abandonnée
par mon gouvernement nous nous fions aux
informations sur internet et personne ne
sait ce qui se passe
nous avons été vaccinées trois fois en
bon citoyen nous avons fait tout notre
possible
et maintenant nous ne pouvons pas
rentrer chez nous
je suis dévasté je suis frustré j'ai
pleuré toute la journée j'espérais juste
rejoindre mes enfants et maintenant on
ignore quand on sera capable de repartir
j'ai déjà 76 ans cela me fait peur parce
que finalement je pourrais quitter ce
monde demain sans avoir vu ma famille
les prix des billets d'avion des
derniers vols du pays ont largement
augmenté ainsi que ceux des tests pcr
obligatoire alors que la communauté
internationale est consciente du fait
que cette sud africain sur dix n'ont pas
été vaccinés
cela s'explique en partie par le manque
d'accès aux vaccins dans le pays mais
aussi par l'inquiétude de nombreux
sud-africains à propos des conséquences
à long terme des vaccins sur la santé
les scientifiques locaux se sont
obstinés a expliqué que le nouveau
variant n'était pas d'origine
sud-africaine et insiste sur le fait
qu'il provient d'une autre partie du
monde
or au lieu d'être remerciée pour ses
justifications l'afrique du sud a été
mis sur liste noire